Ray Cromwell: Okay, so...
Hi, my name is Ray Cromwell,
and I'm CTO of a company
called Timefire.
And this presentation's
sort of a...
if you saw my presentation
earlier on GQuery,
this is sort of a little bit
higher level
and more of an ad hoc
presentation
about how to use G-W-T
and many of the other
Google APIs
to sort of build--or at least
try to build a product.
So this is really about
my personal experience
over like the last year
of trying to build
an application
and sort of
the steps that I took
and how I was able to leverage
Google's offerings
to sort of fill in holes
in what I was trying to do
and sort of increase
my productivity.
So...
this presentation should
have been called
"There's an API for that"
instead of
"Building with Google APIs"
because it seems there's
about seven presentations
called
"Building with something".
The one before in this room
was also called
"Building with something."
But really, if you look
at what's going on with Google,
they're releasing
a tsunami of APIs.
If you just go
to code.google.com,
you'll see about 60 APIs
alone,
and those are just sort of
the publicly documented ones.
If you go
to code.google.com./p
and search for sort of projects
that Googlers work on,
there's far many...
far more than that.
And they cover the full spectrum
of needs for
an application developer
for, you know, you have
client side frameworks,
sever side frameworks.
You have cloud services.
You have mobile.
You have social.
You have commerce.
Basically, if you have a need,
there's probably an API for it.
And, you know, that leads me
to sort of pose the question
does Google have a platform?
Because if you look at it,
it's starting to get that way.
You know, people have been
sort of joking for years
that, you know, Google should
do a web operating system,
and I think, you know,
they're dangerously close
to that right now.
Maybe Wave will be that.
So...
here's what I see as sort of
the Application Ecosystem
that Google offers right now.
So I've sort of divided things
up into several blocks.
And on the upper left-hand side,
you have client technology.
So you can write today.
You can write client side code
in JavaScript.
You can do it in Android.
You can do it with Flash,
actually.
Like for example,
Google Maps API
has a Flash client API.
G-W-T, of course.
What was just released
recently--O3D browser plugin.
And actually, a lot of people
don't really realize
that that icon in the upper
left corner is Google Earth,
but Google Earth includes
a full HTML5 WebKit browser
in it.
So you can actually author
complete applications
and run them and host them
inside of Google Earth itself.
So then we move on over
to the server.
And typically, when people
do server applications,
they have their choice
of PHP, Java, Python, Ruby,
everything in the LAMP framework
that people are used to
However, now with AppEngine,
sort of a curious thing happens.
You can run all of these
on Google's own servers today.
So in a sense,
Google is sort of providing
hosting services
for all of these languages,
whether they have officially
announced it or not.
The...
another crucial thing is
how do you communicate
between a client server?
So if you're building
a rich client like Flash
or Android or G-W-T,
you typically
have to communicate
between a client and server,
ship data back and forth.
There's a number of different
ways to do that.
Probably people's favorite way
of doing it
is with REST and JSON
or some kind of XML format
like Atom.
Or there's an API called
ProtocolBuffers
which Google actually uses
for all of their internal stuff
which is very compact,
and it has high performance.
And for G-W-T, if you're using
G-W-T on a client side,
you have the option
of GWT RPC,
and I'll talk about maybe
how you can choose
which one of those will fit
your application best
a little bit later.
And then, you know,
all the rage now is OpenSocial,
Well, not OpenSocial,
but social networking.
So Google has quite a number
of different ways
to build social applications.
You can use OpenSocial,
you can use
Google Friend Connect,
and you can actually use
the GData Contacts API
to basically sort of have
pseudo friends network
using like your Gmail contacts.
And that's not
quite as well-known.
They provide
a lot of utility services,
which you see reused
over and over again,
like in the Wave demo today,
you saw translation.
Google provides
translation service.
You have Maps and Geo,
of course.
Visualization for charting.
Search, authentication
like through...
Google User service
on AppEngine.
And then there's App Services,
so for example, if you wanna
store spreadsheet data or...
you know,
other kinds of documents,
you can use Google Apps.
And there's GData APIs
for all of those,
so you can integrate them
into your application.
Finally, if you want to monetize
your application you just built,
down in the right-hand
corner you have
AdSense
and Google Checkout.
And I'd be remiss
if I didn't mention
the fact that you can choose
to write applications today
that transparently can move
back and forth
between Google's AppEngine
datastore and MySQL,
and I'll talk about that
a little bit later.
Let me talk a little about
my application
just as a way
to sort of demonstrate
what I've been trying to build
and how I was able to sort of
consume these APIs.
So basically, I started off
with trying to build
a application that was like
"Google Maps" but for "Time".
The idea there was
basically Google Maps
handles the spatial dimensions
really well.
You can fly over vast datasets,
you can drop markers on them.
People can collaborate.
But there was nothing out there
that sort of allowed people
to, you know, search for
vast amounts of time series data
and fly over, just like
you would do in Google Maps,
drop annotations on it,
and, you know,
share your own insights
about that data.
So I started to try to build
an application like that.
So the first thing I did was
I looked at client technologies.
And one of the things I did was
I originally wrote
a Charting API
using pure JavaScript by hand.
So the first thing I did was--
this was before GWT 1.3--
I said, all right,
let me go use JavaScript.
So I wrote a Charting API
in JavaScript
and, to tell you the truth,
it kinda sucked.
[laughs]
Not because of JavaScript's
fault, per se,
but there was a lot of things
I wanted to do
with the Charting API
that it was just hard to do
with JavaScript.
Like I wanted to run it
on the server
to generate thumbnails.
I wanted to run it
in mobile devices.
And I just couldn't do that
with the library written
in hand code in JavaScript.
So the first step was
as I got exposed to GWT,
and I was like, wow,
I could write code in Java,
and maybe, besides just
compiling it to JavaScript,
maybe I could actually
run it in a servlet
and generate thumbnails.
And maybe I could run it
on J2ME devices.
This was before Android.
So this is an example
of the charting library I built,
and one of the core features
I needed was performance.
I was very, very concerned
about performance,
because, you know,
looking at Google Maps,
I was thinking, you know,
people could load up
time series datasets
that were huge--
tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands,
millions of data points,
potentially.
And I wanted people
to just be able
to smoothly fly over
that data...in real time
without any kind of hiccups
in the browser.
And G-W-T was able to help me
deliver that kind of performance
in their browser.
So for example,
this is an example
of a dataset.
It's got 22,000
data points in it.
So I can like zoom in over this
in real time.
You see how fast it updates.
It's 80 frames per second.
It's actually faster than most
games you'll get on your Xbox
or Playstation 3
in terms of their update rate.
Um...it allowed me to do
stuff like real-time streaming
using Comet
and streaming data in.
Synthetic Dataset overlays,
like, you know, let me add
a moving average to this.
That's another example.
But one of the cool things
I wanted to do
is I wanted people to be able
to tell stories about the data,
so you know, be able
to drop a marker on a data
and say, hey, look at this,
something important here.
Like maybe this point
right here in this dataset,
which I think is unemployment,
you know, maybe it represents
something important,
so, you know,
maybe I should, you know,
add a marker there like this
so that my friends can see it.
I got clipped a little bit.
But you can also--
I can do something
like add an access marker.
I'm gonna try this.
You could put one down there,
and that could represent like
a split in a stock or something.
And you click it
and a little pop-up pops up
just like in Maps.
So this was like the genesis
of the idea,
and I don't wanna talk about
this too much,
'cause I'm not really here
to plug that.
I want to sort of describe
my experience
in trying to build this thing.
So I got this far.
And I was like, well,
what can I do next, right?
Because this is just a chart.
You know, big deal.
There's lots of charting
libraries out there.
So I needed to take it
to the next level.
And...one of the ways
I did that
was by looking at how I could
make it more social.
So I started looking
at OpenSocial
and stuff like
Google Friend Connect.
And I went and I built a...
a widget that imbeds this
whole thing
in an OpenSocial container.
So what I'm gonna show you is
a demo of something called--
that I call Timelord.
And this is that
Charting Application
but hosted in an OpenSocial
container.
And I'm not showing it live,
because actually
I broke something this morning
in my code,
so it actually didn't work.
I'm gonna show you
a screencast of this.
And what this is
is basically
you can drop this chart
in an OpenSocial container,
and people can...
annotate the data,
make comments on it
just like a YouTube video,
and it will actually
post those comments
to the person's activity streams
to their friends.
So for example, you see up
there on the top left it says
Al Gore left a comment on
CO2 EPICA Ice Core with Modern.
So he left some kind of comment
on a chart about CO2 data.
So I'm gonna click that
and move forward a little bit.
And you can see,
lo and behold,
there's a chart here
with 800,000 years of CO2 data.
Going back really far.
And on the right-hand side
you see a little YouTube-like
interface that says,
"please
watch my mini-presentation."
So as I was building this
and adding the features
for people to drop markers
and log things to OpenSocial,
I thought, you know,
why not let the person
tell a story
while they're at it?
It's not enough to just say
drop a marker here
and say there's something
funny going here,
there's like
something interesting here.
What if I could
tell a story about
like why I think this data
is the way it is?
So one of the APIs I looked at
to do this was
the YouTube Chromeless
Player API.
I don't know
if anyone's used it,
but this is an enormous
productivity benefit
because if I didn't have that,
I'd have to actually build out
a video hosting service myself,
build my own Flash Player,
export APIs for it.
It would be just
a tremendous hurdle.
I actually was able to implement
what you're about to see
in one day.
So what you're gonna see
is a clip from Al Gore's movie,
"An Inconvenient Truth."
And on the right-hand side,
the video's gonna play
and Al Gore's gonna
walk across the stage,
and he's gonna point out
various things
about the data you're seeing.
And on the left-hand side,
the chart is going to react
to what he's saying,
and it's going to basically
add things.
So I'm gonna move it up
a little bit
so we don't have to watch
too much of the movie
and maybe get sued by
the MPAA or something.
But here...at the top you see
there's a subtitle
and it says
CO2 going back 800,000 years.
Now, he's going to talk
about this chart
and what parts of the chart
are in different eras.
So I could turn on the audio.
I don't know if you can hear it.
Al Gore:...outside of
a small group of scientists
has seen this image.
This is the present day,
uh, era.
And that's the last Ice Age,
then it goes up.
We're going back in time now,
650,000 years.
That's the period of warming
between the last two Ice Ages.
That's the second
and third Ice Age back--
fourth, fifth, sixth,
and seventh Ice Age back.
Now, an important point.
In all of this time,
650,000 years,
the CO2 level
has never gone above
300 parts per million.
Now, as I said, they can
also measure temperature.
Here's what the temperature...
Cromwell: So Al's gonna make
a RPC call to the server
and get a temperature dataset,
and now we'll this.
This is all being driven by
text comments
that are hidden behind
this video in actual comment.
So there you go.
It's compared with temperature.
So I'm not gonna
let that go on too long.
But the key issue is here
is basically
I created the system
where people could write
little wiki-like syntax comments
in the commentary, just like
you would do on YouTube.
And you're able to reference
things from the chart
and drop markers,
tell the chart to move somewhere
and to compare it
with other datasets
and all kinds of
like funky stuff.
And by using the YouTube
Chromeless Player API,
I was able to get
bi-directional syncing
between the chart and the video
up in like one day.
So if you move the chart around,
the video actually can
go to the certain time code
to actually react to where
that chart was supposed to be.
You can sort of map
the time code of the video
to like the timeline
on the chart itself.
So without...showing
too much more of that,
now I wanna start talking about,
if you guys thought
that was interesting,
how did I do that?
But before I go forward,
I wanna show you
another cool thing.
Because I think
this is important
when I get to
talking about G-W-T.
I built an Android version
of this.
Now, the interesting thing
about this,
if I can get it working...
here we go...
is that I didn't change
any of the code
in the web version.
I was able to compile
the web version
that you just saw the point
in the OpenSocial container
to a native Android App.
It's not running
in the web browser.
It's a native App
Java bytecode,
or Dalvikvm code,
and just have it run in here.
So you'll be able to see...
it's doing some stuff now
with OAuth
which I'll talk about
a little bit later,
but it's gonna
go get a token.
I'm gonna log it in.
Let me skip ahead.
It's gonna ask me to approve,
give me an OAuth token.
And there you see the same
sort of chart data.
It's dropped some markers
on the chart.
There's the ability to...
go look at those markers,
what the comments were
that people said.
You can add a marker
that you can share via
a number of different networks.
So in this example,
it's gonna share...
a comment via OpenSocial REST
with Al Gore.
And what happens is
when someone clicks this
and says,
I want to share this comment
that I just made on this chart,
it uses a REST OpenSocial API
to post it back
to the container here.
So now I'm gonna
go click on the inbox
on my Partuza
OpenSocial container
and you can see in the sent box
that there's a message
sent to Al Gore,
which says
come look at this chart.
And I did that completely
from the mobile device.
So it's like
the same functionality
that's available
in the OpenSocial container
is also available
on the mobile device.
So hopefully,
that kinda gives you
a taste of some of the cool
stuff you can do.
The question is
like how do you do it,
and how do you do it
without repeating code
and running two clients
and things like that?
So that's what I'm gonna
try to explain
which is how to achieve...
what I would say
is a lot of code re-use,
between various client
technologies.
So first thing
you should know about Android
if you don't already,
it's almost
a full J2SE Java stack.
It has tight integration
with the WebKit browser.
You have a local database,
you have 2D and 3D APIs.
You have sort of
an externalized way
of representing
widget layouts,
which makes it really easy
to separate presentation
and logic.
So...how was this done,
right?
Even in the Android Client,
how is it done?
Well, G-W-T
is the foundation.
If I didn't have G-W-T,
I wouldn't have been able
to do this.
So what happened is
is that I write the App
to the G-W-T APIs
with are a subset
of the normal Java APIs.
And if you target those
and you stay within those APIs,
it turns out that you can
compile that code cleanly
and run it on Android
with very little changes.
So, you know, you could
write a game
that works
in an OpenSocial container
on a social network,
and then you could make
that same game run
on the Android device and
put it on the Android Market.
So I hope that's like
a very compelling use case.
Now, obviously, though,
there are platform-specific
things you have to do,
so, you know, you just can't
target the, you know,
GWT Emulation Library
when you need to draw stuff
on Android
or talk to native Android
widgets or handle events.
So this is where...
Guice comes in.
Guice Dependency Injection.
So hopefully,
some of you have attended
those sessions at Google IO
on dependency injection
in the Guice Library.
But I use this all over,
and I've kind of fallen
in love with it.
And so basically
what you do is this.
You write as much code
as you can,
sort of cleanly packaged
and only using the GWT
JRE Emulation Library classes.
And the 1.6 event system
in GWT,
which there's a pack
that's called shared,
and if you stick
to those interfaces,
it can run in the server,
on the client, anywhere.
It's sort of abstracted away
from the browser.
And then what you do
is for device-specific
or platform-specific stuff
that you need to do
like wire up event handlers
or draw stuff to the screen,
you use dependency injection
to inject implementations
of those particular bits
of functionality.
So like one of the things
I do to draw the chart
is I use the HTML5 canvas
in the browser
to do all the line drawing.
But on Android, I actually
don't use the HTML5 canvas.
I use the native Android
Graphics Libraries.
So what I did is
I just simply created
an interface called canvas
that has many of the methods
like line and set colors
and fill this and translate
and scale and rotate.
And then I dependency inject
different versions.
So on GWT,
I will dependency inject
the one that's the HTML5 canvas
and on Android,
I'll dependency inject
the one that's a native
Android implementation.
So you do have to write some
extra code on each platform,
but it's very small.
You maybe have to implement
one or two classes
to get it up and running.
Very powerful.
One tricky thing is
wiring up EventHandler.
So you know, the event handling
system on Android's
completely different
than the browser one.
On, you know, GWT you have
ClickHandlers or ClickListeners.
On Android, it's
a completely different system.
But what you can do is this.
You can code all of your stuff
to the GWT 1.5--
sorry, 1.6. event system
that was introduced.
And they have interfaces
like HasClickHandler
and has a method on it
like addClickHandler,
and it takes the callback
function.
It's gonna be called
when you--
when somebody clicks
on that widget.
And what you do is you
inject the device-specific
implementation
of that interface.
So for Android, you might
inject Android ClickHandler
And for GWT, you might inject
like a browser ClickHandler.
And essentially on GWT,
the Guice API's called GIN,
so if you haven't heard of it,
it's sort of under the radar.
It's one of those APIs
that's not on code.google.com.
There is a dependency injection
framework for GWT called Gin
which is actually just Guice
but implemented for Gin.
So this is one way
where you can write
one set of logic
for handling events
and then sort of cleanly inject
platform-specific event handlers
if you need to.
Like if you need to specifically
handle something
differently for the Android
device versus the browser.
Typically, it boils down
to like network IO.
Like, you know,
you need to either
inject a script tag on GWT
to basically load up
a rest call
or on Android you have to use
the HTTPClient--
things like that.
So, what's Guice?
It's dependency injection
like Spring,
if you've used Spring before,
but without the XML cruft.
So it's all done with...
annotations.
And they use a lot of
of method chaining,
so if you saw my GWT Query
or GQuery presentation earlier,
it uses the method chaining
technique
to sort of make your code terse.
It's very compact,
but it's very powerful.
And there's the thing--
it now works as a Guice 2.0
inside of AppEngine,
on Android, and in GWT.
That means you can write code
that you can deploy
to AppEngine on the server,
run it as JavaScript,
or run it inside
the mobile device.
So there are some times
you want to write code
that actually can run
in all three places,
'cause it's very generic
utility code.
So as I said, Gin is basically
Guice for G-W-T.
it uses compile-time generators
to do AOP-dependent style
method interception and stuff.
Here's an example of what
dependency injection looks like
if you've never seen it.
So I could write a class called
Checkout
and maybe it has to take another
class called OrderProcessor
that knows how to process
the order.
And typically,
the way you would write this
is you might have
an OrderProcessorfactory
you might call create
or getInstance,
and it would basically return
the instance--
the actual implementation
of OrderProcessor.
There might be different
versions of OrderProcessor,
depending on whether
you're against Checkout
or whether
you're against PayPal.
Maybe for testing you've got
a MOP OrderProcessor.
But with Guice what you do
is you just write @inject on
the constructor of this class.
And that's it.
You're done.
And then basically,
there's a little config class
you write later
where you say,
"Well, in this instance,
"I wanted to inject
the PayPal OrderProcessor,
"and in this instance,
I want it to be at the Google
Checkout OrderProcessor."
So it allows you sort of the rip
and replace functionality
out of your code really easily
without being too tangled
on factories
and other stack dependencies.
So this is
a list of the APIs
that I'm gonna try to talk
about or cover in some way.
And these are the ones
that I've kind of been
prototyping
and using with my application.
OpenSocial, Friend Connect,
GWT, Android.
Those are the tops.
GViz. I'll show you a GViz
integration in a second.
Hopefully, you'll find that
a little bit cool.
Maps, ring tones, and...[laughs]
Spreadsheet.
YouTube, Checkout.
You saw the YouTube integration
already.
So first let's talk about
Social, right?
So there's usually three things
when you wanna sort of...
integrate Social
into your application, right?
You want to get
a list of the friends
of the current
authorized user,
you want to send messages
to those people sometimes,
and you want to post
activities
like, you know, somebody
just did this on this app,
like I attained level 10 in,
you know, Sudoku or something
so your friends can see it.
And there's two current ways--
I classify Google Friend Connect
as like a sub-class,
so there's two current things
that Google provides
that allow you to write
applications
that leverage Social,
unless you want to use
Facebook or something.
You can use OpenSocial
and Google Friend Connect,
and there's two different ways
to do it.
You can use the Java Script APIs
or the REST APIs.
And then there's the Google Data
Contacts API.
And you can use that
in some instances
where you're not inside
an OpenSocial container.
The question is
is like how do you integrate...
OpenSocial with GWT
and Android at the same time
and limit the amount of code
that you're duplicating
between the two?
So typically,
what you might do
is take the JavaScript APIs
on GWT for OpenSocial
and use overlay types,
or JSNI, to wrap them.
That's what a lot of people
would do.
And then for Android,
you would probably use
the REST APIs
and you would fetch JSON
from the server
using HTTP GETs.
But then you might
get tired of that,
because there's duplication.
You gotta maintain
these overlay type classes
with all these
adjusting methods,
then you've gotta maintain
these REST classes,
and they're sort of different.
So you don't want to
repeat yourself.
So the other thing
you can do is...
you can instead delegate
the fetch logic on the server.
So I could put all the
OpenSocial logic on the server
that communicates with,
let's say, MySpace
and pulls your Friends lists
that logs activities,
and then I could make the client
simply ask the server
to do it on their behalf.
But then the problem is
is that how do you talk to
the server
using like Android and GWT
and maybe Flash
and other things like that?
So obviously, what we'd like
is like option 3,
which is like both on GWT
and on Android.
It's basically
the same API.
It's like ask the server
to fetch it on your behalf
via an RPC call.
So I'll...
cover that in a second.
Let me just
digress for a moment.
The way I implement it
is I create an interface
called ShareProvider,
and it has three methods on it--
getContacts, sendMessage
and logActivity.
And then I use Guice to inject
one of these three options here
which I've experimented with
on each of the platforms.
But obviously the best is to
only inject one implementation,
which is option 3,
which is both of them delegate
to the server and say,
"Get me my Friends list."
So...
I'll just skip that
for a second.
So how do you communicate
with the clientless server
in sort of a cross
client-agnostic way?
We have three options.
You can use REST with JSON
or XML,
which is what many people
would do today
and many people would favor.
But it's still kind of like
the de facto standard.
It's readable.
You can look in Firebug
and you can kind of see
what's going back and forth
over the wire.
It's easy to debug.
But there are reasons why
you might not wanna do it.
You can use ProtocolBuffers
which is what Google uses
internally
for almost all their stuff.
So when you're doing searches
or you're using Tchat
or spreadsheets or whatever,
on the back end somewhere,
there's like ProtocolBuffers
flying around Google's cluster.
And then the other option
is GWT RPC,
which is built into GWT.
So the question is which one of
those three would you use?
Well, let's look at REST,
for example.
You basically
have to write code
that serializes or de-serializes
your objects to JSON or XML.
So if you're using GWT,
like I am
and you've got a Java class
and you've got to make
a utility class
that can basically
take a GWT object
and generate JSON from it
or generate XML.
The pros is that you can port
this technique to any client
or sever code.
So, you know, you can write
a Python Library
to interact with the same
servers that the GWT does,
the GWT client does.
And it's also very efficient
for the browser,
so like JSON, you know,
you can directly evaluate it
in a browser if you want.
It's kind of very
targeted JavaScript,
in terms of efficiency.
The problem I ran into--
because this is the first
implementation I did--
is that if, you know,
one of the other guys
who were working on our stuff,
he changes one of the Java
objects
and adds an extra field
or he renames a field,
what happens is
is that everything breaks.
And often, you don't know
that it's gonna be broken
until you actually test it
in web mode
or you test it end-to-end...
which is kind of bad.
I'd prefer to know
when I'm editing the code
that he refactored something.
And also,
it's less efficient for mobile.
So, you know, if you wanna
conserve battery power
on these devices
and you wanna decrease
the latency,
you want to stay off
the radio as much as possible
and download as few bytes
as possible.
And then once you got
the data in,
you don't want to take
that much time to parse it.
So for Android,
you'd have to download
sort of a very verbose
JSON syntax
then convert all the numbers
from ascii into like
actual doubles
or floats or whatever.
And it could be a bad
experience for mobile users.
So ProtocolBuffers
are an alternative, right?
So like I said,
they're used by
all Google services.
They're compact and fast.
They have this, actually,
this feature of composeability
which is not too important
for what we're talking about.
They're forward-compatible,
what will happen is
is let's say someone has
a ProtocolBuffer
which is just like
a data structure
you can send back and forth.
And it has four fields in it
let's say like your
first name, last name,
you know, age and gender.
And somebody comes along
and they add another field.
Well, what happens is,
a client who is working with--
who's inspecting the other one
that only had four fields,
and now he gets one
with a fifth field,
can kind of conveniently
ignore these extra fields.
So it's kind of
forward-compatible.
It's a very nice feature.
However, it doesn't have
any built-in polymorphism,
so you can't have like
sub-classes.
Like you can't have
an animal protocol buffer
that has like a dog and cat
and horse like subtypes,
sub-message types.
But you can fake it.
However,
I like to use GWT RPC,
and the reason I like
to use GWT RPC
is that there's no pain
to using it.
You write an interface.
You implement the interface
in a servlet.
and then on the client
you invoke GWT RPC--
GWT.create on the interface,
and it just works.
And the performance
is very reasonable.
And another cool thing
is actually, you know,
you can sort of step through
an RPC call
on your Java debugger
and have the break point
run on the server.
You can step like from client
to server almost.
That's pretty cool.
The problem is
it's very GWT-specific.
You know, about about Android?
If you wrote your servlet
using GWT RPC,
how can people
who are using Android
talk to your servlet now?
Well, one of the things
I've been experimenting with,
and this is something--
I always try to throw in
something
that's a little, you know,
off the beaten path--
is using Android to talk
to GWT RPC servlets.
So we implement GWT RPC
on the server,
but then on the client
we implement GWT RPC in Android.
An the way you can do this is
is if you use
dependency injection,
you can inject an implementation
of an RPC interface on Android.
But let's say it's like,
you know, customer service,
and there's a method called
like, you know, get...
get account representative
or something, right?
So it's an abstract interface.
And what you can do in Guice
is you can inject
a implementation of this
by intercepting method calls
to it.
Now, with Guice, basically,
I use this AOP Library,
AOP Alliance Library
for doing that,
and unfortunately,
it doesn't run on Android.
'Cause Android doesn't want you
to dynamically modify byte code.
But what Android does support
is the original sort of
method interception technology
that's built into the J2SE
that not many people use
which is the
java.lang.reflect.Proxy.
So what you can actually do
is you could intercept calls
to that interface
using this object
and dynamically implement
a call to a method
that has no underlying
implementation.
So your get account
representative thing
can be intercepted,
and you can catch
that attempt to invoke it
and then use what's called
the SerializationStreamWriter
that comes in G-W-T
to invoke an RPC method
over the wire.
So you'd use the
SerializationStreamWriter,
encode your method invocation,
and then use the HTTPClient
to just send that over
as like a post to the server.
So it's...
I've prototyped it.
It's kind of cool,
and if it can be made to work,
Then you could actually
write one servlet
that can serve mobile devices,
could serve GWT
and maybe even
server-to-server calls.
So I'm going to
digress a little bit
and talk about
user management.
So when you develop
an application these days,
usually one of the first
things you start out with
is making the user table
in your database.
'Cause you gotta have users.
So you gotta start using
a password,
you gotta have a sign-up
method.
You've gotta be able
to authorize them, and so on.
But if you don't want to go
through all that hassle,
what you can do is
if you deploy the AppEngine,
you can leverage the existing
user service API that they have.
In that case,
anybody can log in
with their existing
Google credentials.
The other thing is
is you could use a library
called OpenID for Java,
and you could take
any OpenID credential
from other providers,
like Yahoo has OpenID,
MySpace has OpenID, and so on.
People could log into
your service
with their MySpace credentials
or with their Yahoo credentials,
in which case
you don't have to
spend as much time implementing
the authentication piece of it.
But more than that,
it kind of lowers the barrier
to enter to your app,
because now the user
doesn't have to go through
a really boring sign-up process,
"Let me think up
another password."
You know, "Let me fill out
all my information."
They can just sign in with their
existing credentials.
So that's one of the APIs
that sort of helps
your productivity.
The other key piece, when
you're developing applications,
is you know, how are you
gonna persist your data?
And the traditional way
you do it, of course,
little AMP stack,
is you have my MySQL
and you use Hibernate
or you use Rails
or you use Django.
Use one of those things,
basically,
to take your objects
and map them onto the database.
But Google provides
an alternative to that,
so AppEngine,
as you've probably heard,
is not a relational database.
This is what Google uses
on their back end.
It's totally different
datastore technology.
However, they provide
an object relational layer
based on the JDO standard.
Now, you may not
have heard of JDO
until like Google
started using it.
You probably were using JPA.
JDO kind of died for a while.
And JPA and Harmony
kind of owned it.
But JDO actually has some
features that those don't.
It actually
is more abstract than JPA.
And JPA is tightly bound
to the idea
of a relational database.
JDO is actually so abstract
that it can store data
to almost anything.
So if you write your application
using JDO,
you can move it from MySQL
to AppEngine and back,
but more, if you go look
at the underlying
data nucleus libraries
that Google is using,
you could persist data
into Excel.
You can persist data
into HML.
into almost any storage format.
So I mean, someone can hand you
an Excel file,
you can basically do
a JDO Query across it.
So it's really,
really flexible.
And the interesting
question to me is...
what of the native storage
in HTML5 are Android?
You know, maybe a cool idea
for maybe one of you guys
to explore is
perhaps a JDO Mapping in GWT
for mapping onto the native
storage mechanism
in the browser that's being
made available these days.
But the key takeaway here
is that the JDO APIs that Google
sort of settled on
are very, very flexible,
and you can write an APP
that does not lock you in
to AppEngine in any way.
So if you're sort of thinking,
vendor lock-in,
I'll be stuck on Google...
if you use JDO,
you actually won't.
It's kind of cool.
Okay, so the next thing
that Google provides
which is really powerful
is gadgets.
So a lot of times,
you know...
it might not even be necessary
for you to develop
an application
where you have to, you know,
develop an entire website.
It's possible for you
to develop an application
that lives entirely
within a gadget.
And there have been
some success stories
of people deploying gadgets
on like Google IO
where they've made quite
a bit of money from it.
But one of the cool things
is that if you develop a gadget,
it can be embedded anywhere.
You've seen it embedded
in Google Wave today
at the keynote.
It fits in OpenSocial
containers,
Google Friend Connect sites,
in Maps, Calendar,
Spreadsheets.
In fact, there was just
announced yesterday
the real-time Gadget API
where you can drop gadgets
into the Google chat window
and implement real-time games.
So someone updates
a JavaScript object,
the other people
you're chatting with,
they instantly get notification,
just like in Google Wave.
You get the notification
immediately.
So what I'm gonna show you is,
and hopefully it's gonna work,
I'm gonna show you...
how I was able to leverage
Google Gadgets
to solve a very real problem
I had.
So I had the problem of like
so how do I get data
into my system?
I could write like a really
complex web-based GUI
that was sort of like
a spreadsheet
and allowed you to import a CSV
and some other stuff
and then choose, you know,
what columns I want
and how I want to basically
graph it.
But instead, what I did,
because that seemed
very daunting,
is I leveraged the feature
of Google Spreadsheets,
which allows you to drop Google
GViz gadgets into it.
So here's a spreadsheet
I've got,
and it's got
three time series in it--
price, oil, and food.
And in between, you can see
that there's these columns
called Markers.
So what's gonna happen
is anywhere that there's
a column called Markers
and it has text in it,
it's gonna drop
a GMaps-type push-pin
on that data point in the chart.
So the cool thing is like
if I want to chart
all three of these,
I can just drag, select--
whoops.
Just drag, select that...
and hopefully,
this will work.
The network connection is...
not going to fight me.
And let me just add
a little extra flag there
in case something goes wrong.
Okay, so let me click
apply and close.
And...there we go.
So basically what you can do
is you can write gadgets
that live inside Google Apps,
and what this gives me
is the capability
to say to people who want
to put data into my system
go take your Excel data
or your Google Spreadsheet data
and drop this gadget
in there.
Export your Excel data
into Google Spreadsheets
and drop this gadget in there.
And then you can share it
with people
and publish it to the Web.
So for example, this same
gadget you saw right there,
it can appear on any website.
So here it is embedded
on another website.
Let's wait for it to load.
Oh, there we go.
So here that same gadget
as it's appearing here.
So you don't actually
have to have the gadget
live in the spreadsheet.
You can drop the gadget
in the spreadsheet,
and then you can go put it
in your own application
like you would see here.
And the cool thing
is if somebody updates the data
in the spreadsheet,
it will be reflected here.
So...that is...
how you can make
Google Gadgets
work for you and solve
a pressing API issue,
like if you don't want to
build your own spreadsheet.
So this is leveraging an API
called the Google
Visualization API, GViz.
I don't know if you guys
went to any of the sessions,
but it's kind of
a cool API.
You can pump data into it
using JavaScript for GWT
and out pops any of,
let's say,
15 or 20 different charts,
pie charts, bar charts,
scatter charts,
animated charts
and things like that.
And a lot of the Google
products you see
like Analytics
and all these things,
they kind of leverage
this stuff.
The cool thing is
is that third parties
can submit new extensions.
So let's say you guys
come up with
a new way to visualize data.
Maybe it's a spider graph
or one of these really bizarre
or very artsy-looking graphs,
hyperbolic charts
and things like that.
You can write it up,
and it could be
a JavaScript Library,
it could be a GWT Library,
and you submit it to Google.
And what will happen is
it will appear,
if you submit it to them
and they approve it,
in the spreadsheet.
So when you go here
and you say insert
and you pull up the gadget,
it actually will appear here.
So there's like a list
of all the charts
you can see here.
So it's one way to sort of...
publish gadgets.
And as you can see,
there are commercial
gadgets here.
Like FusionCharts is
actually a commercial product.
So this can be used
to actually drive revenue.
So if you've got
a charting product
and people start
using it here,
maybe they'll buy your license
to your real chart product.
All right, so multimedia.
So let's say you want
to basically
write something
like TwitPic
or one of these other
photosharing services.
Or you wanna do like
a video hosting service.
Rather than build your own
scalable massive picture
and video hosting back in,
you can actually leverage
Google's infrastructure
using either
the Picasa GData API
or the YouTube API.
And what you can do
with these APIs
is not only can you
get a list
of like photos
that you've published to Google,
you can actually upload
multimedia over the API.
So you can take photos,
take videos,
and you can push them
into Google's infrastructure.
And then later on,
you can pull them out.
And it's possible
to develop an API--
sorry, a website that looks
completely different
than a Picasa or YouTube.
You can just sit it on top
of their APIs
and sort of make a clone
website that looks different,
maybe better.
In particular, I use the
YouTube Chromeless Player API,
and this is kind of
an interesting thing.
Let's say you don't like the
way the YouTube Player looks.
So you could write
an application
that pushes video into YouTube
and host it there
using the GData API.
And then you can pull down
their Chromeless Player API,
which is the Flash Player
but without any of
the cruft around it.
And then you could put on
your own UI on top of that,
so you might wanna have
different buttons,
buttons for adding annotations,
sharing with friends.
You might want to totally
redesign the way it looks.
And it's possible to do that.
Obviously, with HTML5 video tag,
it'd be ever easier.
But today you can do it
with the YouTube Chromeless
Player API.
Think of it as a way to sort
of emulate the video tag today
using Google's infrastructure.
Okay, so one of the last things
I wanted to talk about
is Google Checkout.
So we came to--after we did
all the stuff with the chart,
we tried to do
a OEM licensing model.
People said, hey, we want
to license a chart
and we want to basically
use it in our application.
But a number of people
came to us and said,
"We don't want to license it.
"We just want you to host this.
"It's too much effort
for us to do our own builds,
"build our own GWT APPs
and stuff like that.
"We just want to like...you host
the data, you host the chart.
We just wanna
pay a monthly fee."
So approximately,
not even two months ago
when Google AppEngine launched,
we started doing a software
service implementation.
And we came to the problem
of like,
how do we...take orders?
How do we take monthly orders?
And Google recently launched,
if you're not aware of it,
what's called
the subscription API.
So you might have
like an online newsletter
or you're selling some other
kind of digital good
that you want people
to subscribe to
and pay a monthly fee--
maybe it's an online
multiplayer game or something
There's a new API
where you can charge somebody
a reoccurring monthly fee.
So we looked at this
and we said,
oh, wow, this is gonna--
Google Checkout fits exactly
what we wanna do.
We can use this to monetize
our software as a service.
However...
you know, how do we
integrate with it, right?
There's a number of different
ways to integrate with it,
an we sort of needed
a lower level of control
of how Order Processing works.
And Google
lets you have as much
or as little control
as you want.
So you could tell Google,
handle all aspects
of the Google Checkout process.
Like all I ever want
to see from you at the very end
is an email that says you
charged the person's credit card
and shipped the order to them.
So they can handle
the entire workflow.
Or you can actually intercept
that process
at any point in time
with several APIs
like the Merchant Calc API,
the Notification API,
the Order Processing API
and react to the different
stages of the order process.
So we actually integrated
with the Notification API.
We wanted to be notified
after the person submitted
the shopping cart
so that we could do
additional things
like send you an API Key
for using our widgets
and things like that.
So this is what a checkout
flow looks like,
and there's various parts
where you can integrate into it.
We integrate only at
the level of Notification API.
That's like the second
divider over.
So the question is
how do you do it?
There's many different ways
to do it,
and we chose to use
the XML API to export.
And since we were on AppEngine,
we had to figure out
how do we do this quickly,
'cause we were trying to do it
in two months before IO.
We were trying to ready
this whole thing
so that we could
show it off at IO.
And there's this API that
comes with Java called JAXB.
I don't know how many people
are familiar with it,
but it basically
allows you to map--
just like JDO can map
database data
into object/relational mapping
into Java objects,
JAXB can map XML
into Java POJOs.
So what we did--
Java beans, basically.
Java POJOs.
Plain old Java objects.
So you can say, I want this tag
to go into this field
and this tag to go
into this field
and this attribute to go
into that field, and so on.
And it's bi-directional,
so you can take Java objects
and turn them back into XML.
The cool thing is
is that you start with a schema.
So Google publishes
an XML schema
for all of their
checkout-related APIs.
You can pump that into
the JAXB schema compiler,
and what it does
is it looks at the schema
and it generates Java objects
for every HXL element
that's important in the schema.
And then once you got that,
you're pretty much done.
You can take XML
from any source,
like let's say from Google
notifying you,
an XML message
from someone checking out,
and you de-serialize it
into a Java object
and just call
Getters and Setters.
And...this diagram represents
like what we're doing,
so we basically take
notifications back from Google
at the bottom,
and we de-serialize them
in a servlet into Java POJOs.
We do our business logic,
interact with the AppEngine
datastore,
and we send requests back to
the checkout API.
However...if you were to take
what I just told you
and you go ahead and try it,
you're gonna kinda be in
for a rude awakening,
because, unfortunately,
JAXB isn't a whitelisted API
on the AppEngine.
So AppEngine has this notion
of what's allowed,
what APIs are allowed
and which aren't.
JAXB's actually part of
Java 6.
It's part of the package
javax.xml.bind.
But AppEngine
won't let you use it.
So there's
a tricky workaround,
and one of the things
you can do
is you can use
these utilities like JARJAR
or you can use IDE refactoring.
And all you gotta do is move
it into another package.
So you can move like
javax.whatever
in AppEngine.javax,
and once you do that, it works.
So if anybody in the audience
is doing JAXB integration
in AppEngine--
'cause this is a highly starred
issue in the issue tracker.
It's got like 70 votes on it.
If you're interested
in doing it,
I have a build
of the JAXB Libraries
that will work in AppEngine.
So you can send me an email.
So to recap,
there's 60+ APIs documented
on code.google.com.
There's a lot, lot more of 'em
like Guice,
in code.google.com/p.
There's lots of soft-launched
APIs in Google Labs.
And there are related APIs
that are totally hosted
on separated websites.
Like Apache Shindig
is not really a Google API,
but actually, it is
the reference implementation
of OpenSocial.
So if you want to open
Social container,
make your own social network,
you just go download Shindig,
and you're done.
Chromium, the browser...
and then various OpenSocial
Foundation and Open Web groups
actually have their own
sort of libraries.
And a lot of the people
who are in those groups
are Googlers
who are contributing code.
So sort of a lot of stealth
Google products out there
that you may not know about.
So just to summarize...
there's an API for almost
everything you want to do
as part of your normal
application needs
provided by Google.
But by no means am I saying
like only use Google Services.
You might tie yourself
to Google so tightly
you might find yourself wishing
that, you know,
that you can
get away from them later.
But when you're
developing an App
that does allow rapid
prototyping--
if you want to do
video hosting
and picture hosting,
stuff like that--
there's a back end
infrastructure.
It's very scalable.
You can just leverage
off the bat.
I call it one-stop shopping.
So whenever
I'm developing an App
and I need to do something
and I don't feel like
implementing myself,
I go to Google and see if they
already got something for me.
So that's basically it.
I hope people
got a good taste
of the big variety of APIs
that you can sort of leverage
with Google,
and I'm willing
to take any questions.
[applause]